you
hi everyone is Jerry here is another
composition by Frederic Lazard I feel
like I don't really need to share much
more beyond this guy's name in order to
get your attention the feedback you guys
left on cool chest puzzle 17 which was a
composition by him that was off the
charts a number of you took the time to
write the comments alone tell me well
it's clear quite clear many of you were
in awe of its solution of his work of
his creativity I think you're really
going to like this one in a way probably
setting ourselves up for some
disappointment later on in this playlist
when I share a puzzle that is on the
Lazard like let's just say okay you get
the idea I think we have another really
good one here it's white to move it's up
to you to try and find the best
continuation and someone had asked me in
the last video did you solve it and I
said yes but only after staring at it
for a good 30 minutes so these do or can
take some time so if you have the time
feel free to put some in and work this
one out again white to move try and find
the best continuation okay I don't think
many of you are going to be ready for
what I'm about to say and I think I'm
going to shock many of you right now
listening ooh I think those of you who
actually pause the video and put any
amount of time and trying to solve this
one I think I'm going to shock many of
you
by what I'm about to say I don't even
have to make a move on the board just
listen to what I'm about to say you're
ready for this suppose I gave you a hint
suppose I told you this is white to move
and win white to move and win by
emphasizing it like this is because I
just how could you possibly win this one
that's why those many of you might be
frowning right now scratching your head
both both probably
this is a position that Y could win you
don't have to check the date this is
it's not April 1st this is light to move
and win wrap your head around that wrap
your head around that why to move and
win you got to be kidding no are you
ready to see how white pulls a rabbit
out of a hat this is stunning this is a
stunning puzzle now with that hint feel
free I mean I imagine many of you were
trying to find a way to draw maybe you
know some tricky stalemate no I could
win this one so if you'd like to pause
the video again and work this one out
knowing that Y could actually win feel
free to do that I'm just going to get
right into the solution here are you
ready for this one how can we possibly
give this is what these are one a couple
of thoughts I had how can we possibly
win this how can we get upon here to
attack the king or this guy here surely
this pond will stop this guy and well
where's our Jeep on bishops not going to
control f8 we win this yeah you're ready
for this rabbit out of a hat solution
King g6 a3 who's going to win the race
h6 a to h7 Oh black wins that's ok
that's quite all right
each a equals Queen now before I show
you what happens after Queen takes Queen
let me just point out ok suppose black
gives a check eventually these checks
run out Queen takes c3 Queen take c3 we
would have Queen f6 and we got all sorts
of stuff the checks run out check there
check here King h7 and there's just too
many different threats White's going to
be winning there if he comes the Queen
comes here eventually the checks run out
as well like this
Queen e5 and we're getting out the black
King soon enough ok point here is that
white will go on to win
if the queen is not captured well light
will still win after the queen is
captured but how Queen takes Queen what
are we doing here
you ready f6 I'm still here I just I
wanted that little pause right there for
you to digest what just happened this
one move killed both king and queen
they have no moves where are you going
to go two pawns and a bishop killed both
king and queen yeah
oh but black does this move h3 so now
the Queen's ready to sneak away hang on
we got that covered in g5 what are you
doing now black this is now we go into
Phase two of this puzzle we recognize at
this point here both king and queen
black king and queen here are paralyzed
can't really do anything so now we turn
towards center in Queen side and how
exactly do we now move the pawns about
we have to be very delicate
d for and now there is only one correct
reply in this position and this is what
you needed to work out and it's
difficult enough to get into this
position here where the two pawns and
Bishop kill both king and queen but what
are we doing when it comes time to the
pawns here after d4 it is important that
you not capture a d4 why it's because
black has a stalemate resource if you're
capturing this allows d5 now what if you
capture the pawn Queen takes pawn you
better capture the Queen if you don't
you're going to lose so after you
capture the Queen Black is in stalemate
you have to be aware of this resource
that black has so you need to make sure
that one of these pawns can continue
moving and the way to do that is to push
c6 let me point out after this capture
in here if you're just doing this it's
the same story capture capture stalemate
on board so the trick here is to meet
the move d4 with c6
white is two moves away from getting a
queen and delivering mate therefore D
take C e takes D only now and now we
have the move C 5 if you capture we're
going to have chop-chop and stalemate so
we just sneak right by who's going to
win this race it's clearly going to be
white by a tempo and check mate I think
we're being spoiled here I'm glad I
discovered this Frederick Lazard in his
work what a creative mind
I just I'm having a lot a blast checking
out his compositions and sharing them
with you did you get this solution again
I think I don't know knowing that this
is a light to move and win is just
something really shocking let me know in
the comment section below what your what
your thoughts are on this one really
impressive you would think you know you
can't promote your queen could just be
taken but f6 what a killer move two dead
ducks here
king and queen killed by bishop and two
pawns black tries to escape but no kings
got that covered as well and then this
little pawn race at the end d format by
c6 and then we just sneak right by and
score touchdown what a cool puzzle let
me know what your thoughts are in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you enjoyed it that's all for now
take care I
you